- I heard though that you've always had
kind of sleep issues.
My son has -- he sleepwalks.
You did you sleepwalk?
- I, you know what, I did.
I had a little bit of sleepwalking.
- Yeah, that's scary.
- Well, and I hope it's
not like, hereditary
'cause my mom slept walked --
slept walked, sleepwalked?
- Sleep walked.
- Slept walked.
- Dub, dub, dub.
How do you?
- I don't really know.
(audience coos)
- [Emma] Aw, there's my mom.
We were both sleep
walkers, how about that?
- There you go.
- I'll redirect that.
- Yeah.
- We were both sleep walkers
and actually one time I was sleepwalking
and she was sleepwalking and
we actually ran into each other
and we were both so freaked out
and we realized we were both sleepwalking
and I was just like, this can't be good.
Like, are the doors locked?
What's happening?
- I know, it scares me
'cause I had a friend,
and her brother had it,
and he like walked out on the road
and he had no idea he was in the road.
So I'm like terrified.
- No, that's --
- And we have stairs in our house.
- No!
- So I'm always like,
oh my god, don't find the stairs.
- No, well I hope my
son's not a sleepwalker
but I mean he's two and we're
lucky he hasn't figured out
he can climb out of the crib
'cause he totally is capable.
- Yeah.
- But he just hasn't,
which I thought was
very sweet of him.
- Yeah.
That's different with boys and girls too.
They're a little more behind.
- Yeah, he's just, he's
happy to, you know,
just stay in the crib,
which is nice for now.
- Yeah.
- But I just know
he's gonna climb out one day
and I just hope he doesn't
sleepwalk on top of that.
- Enjoy baby jail while you have it.
(Emma laughs)
Because once they get out
you are like, oh my god!
- No.
- No, you can't draw on the walls.
- No, now he know how to --
- For the fourth time.
- open door knobs and
turn on and off lights.
So, it's like there's a
ghost in my house sometimes.
Like doors are open, lights are --
I'm like, what happened?
- Yeah.
- I just turned all
this off and shut this.
- We had a power outage like,
I don't know, months ago,
and my son was so terrified about it.
So now to say power, he like,
he goes around our house
and always turns off lights.
- Love!
- He's the most --
- Love that for him.
- Energy efficient 6-year old.
- And for you!
- You've ever seen.
He turns off every light.
'cause he's afraid that the
power won't come back on.
- Sad.
- I'm like,
I know there's gonna be some therapy there
in the future.
- That's cool.
- It's fine, it's fine.